[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
just tapped into the group chat live in
the bleacher report app presented by
fanduel my name is greg ivory alongside
live moods live it's game one for the
warriors for the western conference
final the warriors mavericks
how are we feeling today
yeah believe it or not i'm feeling good
your team is in the western conference
finals mine is not however it makes
betting a whole lot easier when my heart
is not involved it's only my head
so i'm loving seeing the bath bomb
loving also the young talent that we've
got in the playoffs right now it's been
really fun to watch so i'm doing good
and excited to talk some basketball with
you
well liv my heart is always into it so
i mean my heart is always going to be
into it and it's going to be into it
with this series with the warriors but
uh my squad they made it to the western
conference finals so y'all already know
i'm in a giving mood i'm in a great mood
going to the game today so i might give
out a lot of things today but we have
socks yes vr bedding custom socks shorts
jerseys
we're giving it all away let's get this
party started get in those comments i
need gifts i need emojis but most
importantly i need winners only please
and in fact
liv i'm about to just give out some of
those custom br bedding socks right off
the bat why not i see
dion fears dion fears
he's a fan of you liv he is a fan of you
so shout out to dion fears you are
walking away with some of these socks
it's game day so you already know you
already know us over here at br betting
we have our eyes on that three by two
the question is will there be two three
pointers in the first three minutes of
the game we asked you on twitter will
the 3x2 cache in the warriors mavericks
game and here are the current results
you guys see them right there yes they
are
the yes they are rocking with the yes
you guys see the results now i need you
guys to get in the comment and and tell
me if the 3x2 is a lock but live i need
you to talk to me first
do you think the 3x2 is a lot tonight
i'm going to be in the building
i was gonna say you being in the
building right off the bat that's good
vibes only so loving that part of it for
sure but also loving the fact that we
have again young superstars a lot of
three-point shooters on both of these
teams
right now in the postseason the
mavericks ranked first in three pointers
made and right behind them is the golden
state warriors second in three-pointers
made so yes i'm loving the three by two
i think if you're gonna have a three by
two in any match up this is the match up
for it to be in and you're going to be
in the building so i'm loving the vibes
liv is loving the vibes i'm going to be
there bringing all the sunset all the
good vibes that i can to the 3x2 but let
me hop into these comments let me hop
into this comments live because it's
time to give out some of these br
betting custom
socks yes the custom socks we're getting
spazzed by a johnson 98 a johnson 98
that is not how you win a hoodie that's
not how you win custom socks by spam in
the comments so uh we're just gonna look
over that he's saying mavs and seven i
don't think that's gonna happen anyway
here we go bom bombing bean he has the
eyes emoji he has the eyes emoji he's
looking he's looking at that three by
two shout out to you i'll give you some
socks for that uh easy lock risky read
easy lock bunch of shooters on both
teams love that take
you're walking away with some of those
socks live
we are all riding we're all riding the
3x2 you're right in it i will be in
attendance i'm riding it so you that are
watching ride along with us let's all
get rich as one happy family now let's
talk major markets money lines against
the spreads and point totals for
tonight's game live let's take a look at
the odds
what are you thinking here
anything that sticks out to you
yeah well i want to start by saying i do
think the warriors are taking game one
steve kerr is back coaching they're
playing at home
there's no denying that the warriors are
a very talented squad i think they get
the dub tonight however i'm really
liking the mavericks to cover it plus
five and a half this is a mavericks team
that has the best against the spread
record in the post season so i'm liking
them to do what they've been doing all
playoffs and that's cover that spread
luca john chich in my opinion cannot be
stopped and this mavericks defense right
now is giving out giving up the third
fewest points to opponents so really
liking their defense really liking luca
not sure anyone can stop him so i'm
gonna rock with the mavericks to cover
plus five and a half
live i mean i i don't dislike that i
don't dislike that i like the way you
started the segment off yeah you think
the way i had to make sure that's all
that matters
that that that's all that matters i can
see them the mavericks maybe maybe
covering but i'm gonna stay away i'ma
stay away from the spread i want to take
a look at the over under four out of the
last five games the mavics the mavericks
played
they went under three out of the last
five games the warriors played
they went under i think this is going to
be a half court series it's not going to
be as back and forth as memphis warriors
or even the suns they were up and down
the court with the mass i think this was
going to be a half course series a lot
of set offenses so i'm rocking with the
under in this one but let me hop into
these comments i want to see what they
are talking about i want to see which
way they are leaning
i see uh richie 21 richie 21 has warrior
spread uh i see d horner four five six
says how about pool for 20 points at
plus 210
hey jordan poole he's one of
one of the warriors assets on that
offense 20 points is not
that many points for him uh if he comes
out and play good if he comes out and
play good 20 points should be easy but
here we go i got one more one more in me
vgh 72 says dallas plus seven he's
buying some points liv he is buying
some points shout out to everybody
yeah it's not a bad idea at all shout
out to everybody that i mentioned you
all are walking away with some br
betting
custom
socks that i do not have but i need to
get those so i'm trying to be as fresh
as everybody that i just mentioned but
we talked major markets now let's talk
player props
it's time for lock or not i'm gonna put
up a prop and i need everybody to get in
the comments and tell me if it's a lock
or not
i'll be generous live i'll be generous
we'll start off with luca donches here
will he score over 33 points tonight
it's sitting at minus 108. talk to me
live and talk to the people you think my
man luca is gonna have a game today
i do i mean i don't think he has a
choice in order for the mavericks to
stay in this game which i'm hoping they
do because i'm taking them to cover luca
has to have a really great game he hit
this over in four of the seven games in
the last series and we saw this warriors
team really struggle to get a point
guard specifically john moran under
control john moran had a heyday against
his warriors team so i'm not sure what
kind of adjustments they've made but
luca to me right now is unstoppable and
he's facing a team that struggles to
guard point guards in general so really
liking him tonight with that 33 plus
like i said he hit this quite a bit in
the last series he averaged 31 and a
half versus the warriors in the regular
season but this is a final series we're
talking about here so loving him for 33
plus
liv's loving it
and i think i like it liv i think i'm
right there behind you i i there's a
trend there's a trend that i'm seeing
with this warriors team
jokish had a great series in the first
round john morant had a crazy series in
the games that he played in the second
round but superstars will be superstars
against this warriors team but it's all
about them stopping the other guys so
with that being said i do think luca
will go off tonight i do think luca will
get his buckets
but with that being said is the
mavericks is his team gonna help him is
the other guys to help him and pinch in
and uh
hopefully i mean
so to some people uh guide them to a win
tonight but i don't see that happening
but let me hop into these comments let
me hop into these comments because i
want to see
what they are talking about
nbbl noah says luke is the best
one-on-one player left in the playoffs
that is very debatable that is very
debatable but luca is good now luca is
really good but there's a lot of good
talent left in the playoffs uh
i got luca over rebounds l hunt 44 says
luca over in rebounds wow that is very
interesting i can't see luca going to go
grab some boards but let's move on
everybody i mention you guys are walking
away with shorts because it's time for
my golden state warriors it's time for a
player on our team we have draymond
green to have over eight rebounds live
is sitting at plus
114 talk to me talk to the people
do you think my man draymond is going to
be out there grabbing rebounds tonight
all right three things on this prop
first thing i love plus money so i
already am interested in this place
secondly we saw draymond rebounding very
well in the last series and i think he
realized just how important rebounding
is to the warriors success so he was
rebounding super well last series and i
think he continues to do that in order
for them to be successful in this series
and he is facing a mavericks team that
in the last 15 is giving up the seventh
most rebounds to opposing centers so
really liking him tonight to hit this
eight plus again plus money he rebounded
well last series so i'm gonna rock with
draymond green tonight eight plus
rebounds i like it liv you sold me over
i love i love the stats love the love
the trends that you brought to this
because i'm right there with you the
warriors need to rebound they know that
it is a point of emphasis in that locker
room and we saw it last in the last game
they played my man looney went crazy on
the boards offense defense went crazy on
the boards 20 plus rebounds draymond
knows the warriors are going to play
that small ball lineup and he's no he's
going to have to rebound he's going to
be the center
in that in that small ball lineup so
with that being said draymond knows he's
going to have to rebound it's a point of
emphasis in that locker room
eight
draymond's a trip he's almost i mean i
don't know maybe a walking triple double
i do think he's going through the hall
of fame do you think he's going to the
hall of fame but
eight rebounds
triple double draymond that's what you
do go get the eight i like it let me hop
into these comments liv let me hop into
these comments see what they're talking
about
uh they're all over looney in the
comments wow i mean i did just mention
looney i got they got looney over seven
boards shout out to you nml brick you
are walking away with some shorts some
shorts of your choice uh
and my man trash trash said love the
username but trash says lock it up and
throw away the key he's locking in
draymond shouts out to you you are also
walking away with some shorts finally we
have
wardell stephen curry to have over three
three-pointers and it's sitting at -162
live talk to me
talk to the people you know how i feel
about these three pointers made and
stephen curry being the player
that's we're betting on
yeah this is an interesting one because
again if you could kind of make the same
argument for step that you make for luka
we have however seen steph curry get
slowed down quite a bit um in the plate
in the playoffs compared to what we see
from him in the regular season the
mavericks in the last 15 are giving up
the second fewest threes to opposing
point guards but again this is finals
this is steph curry this is a pressured
playoff situation so i really don't
worry about it too much plus he has hit
this in every game but won in the
postseason this year so i'm liking it
for him not liking the minus 162 value
the value on that i would never put my
money on however i think you're about to
talk about something that makes the
value a little bit better where you can
still ride with steph to have a big
night from the three-point line so i
would definitely take a look at that
that you're about to talk about over
this because minus 162 just isn't it
liv is dropping nuggets she's dropping
nuggets for y'all but yeah liv i'm i'm
you know i'm really torn on this one i'm
really torn
everybody that watches this show week in
week out know how i feel about three
pointers made in this man stephen curry
if it's anybody else and it's over three
i don't even want to hear it i'm not
even looking at it i'm not gonna bet it
i'll be honest
i'm not gonna bet it but
when it's stephen curry it has my
attention
and this right here has my attention he
only needs three lives you mentioned
he's been doing it almost all playoffs
but the minus 162 uh that one that
that's just
it's it doesn't make him as it doesn't
make it as appealing to me the the the
value just doesn't make it as appealing
to me but do i think steph curry is
going to go out there and make three
three-pointers
absolutely he's been doing it all
playoffs like liv said but i'm in these
comments because i want to see what they
are talking about i want to see which
way they are leaning and uh
i see
i see
joe joe
h-a-o velez07 says the volume is
definitely there meaning steph curry
will be throwing up the shots so i can i
like that i like that take i got one
more one more uh
boomin bean 5 says steph curry is locked
in clay will be off tonight so
steph curry's threes will be reigning
shout out to you you are walking away
with some shorts but liv speaking of
steph we teamed up with our friends over
at fanduel and are hooking you guys up
with a special boost for tonight created
by the nba legend himself charles
barkley we've got my man steph curry
clay thompson and luka doncic to all
make three
plus three pointers tonight and we
boosted it from plus 115 to plus
200 live talk to me talk to the people
my man chuck put this together do you
think chuck
is on to something with this one
yeah definitely onto something i mean
the value there is great at plus 200.
someone in the comments mentioned klay
thompson being off and to be honest with
you he is my one reservation with this
boost i think obviously we saw him in
game six have insane momentum from the
three he was eight for 14. and we've
seen a trend with klay thompson when he
goes ballistic like that
we're bound to see a lit a couple games
in there where he's just he gets a
little cold so i am worried about that
he is facing a mavericks team that in
the last 15 give up the fourth fewest
threes to opposing uh shooting guards
but the fourth most point so i think
klay thompson still gets points on the
board just not sure it'll happen from
the three so a little nervous about that
but hoping that maybe he carries over
some of that momentum from game six to
hit this boost for us loving luka to hit
three plus threes he doesn't have a
choice the mavericks need him and steph
three plus threes like i said he's done
this in all but one game this postseason
so should be easy money this one will be
a sweat but at plus 200 i'm gonna rock
with it
liv is rocking with it hopefully you are
rocking with it as well
i see
mlm brick says chuck might know
something now
chuck just might know something but i'm
gonna tell you what i know
next we are building the same game
par lay that we hit last week i heard we
hit when i wasn't here but you know i
live i i want to be a part of it now i'm
trying to hit today uh you can ride with
us on fendo i need everybody to get in
the comments and tell me what they are
thinking which legs are locks which legs
or not liv let's get right to it we are
starting it off
we're going to start off with my
favorite warrior dre mon green to record
eight plus assists we already talked
rebounds we talked rebounds
now let's talk assist i call them a um
maybe a walking triple double we'll no
no but yeah do you think do you think my
guy is going to go grab eight plus
assists tonight
i think walking double double is
probably a more appropriate thing to
call him at this point in time and maybe
he switches it up on us in this series
maybe he you know he steps it up a
little bit we see a little bit more
scoring from him but you know i think he
there's obviously a lot of shooters on
this team and and if there's one guy on
the team that you kind of trust in that
leadership spot to do the facilitating i
do think it's draymond i think he really
steps into that role maybe takes a
backseat on the offense like we've seen
from him in the postseason so far so
might be a little bit of a sweat because
eight plus that's kind of a lot but
again lots of shooters to feed the ball
to that don't miss all that often so i
think he's good for it we'll call him
the walking double double and hopefully
he hits both eight plus rebounds and
eight plus assists for us
i like that liv the walking double
double with the
walking triple double we'll leave it at
that step and curry let's move on to
steph and curry to score 25 plus points
tonight
think steph can go out there and uh put
up some shots
yeah i mean of course i do it's steph
like i said in a pressured playoff
position he's the guy i trust the most
on this team from an offensive
perspective i think it's been
interesting to watch steph in the
postseason this year because he's had
help i mean you've got jordan poole who
plays exceptionally well kind of feels
like a mini steph a little bit klay
thompson when he's hot he's great so
it's been interesting to watch him in
the regular season in four games versus
the mavs in the regular season the maps
figured out how to guard him pretty
stinking well he only averaged 20 points
i say only only you know that's still a
good amount of points but for steph not
really that's pretty low for steph so
interested to see what see what he
brings in game one in the last 15 the
mavs are giving up the third fewest
points to point guards so
he has his work cut out for him because
like i said this mavericks defense is
pretty legit but in a playoff final
series i trust steph to get the job done
so i'm gonna say he gets it done but we
may be sweating it out a little bit
liv say he gets it done but we might be
sweating let's move on to this next one
because i i want to know in the comments
you guys let me know was it beer
or apple juice this morning that luca
was drinking with bobon with bobon live
i don't know it it might be some potion
that will give him the motion to be
making shots tonight that's right uh but
you talk to us i feel like how i know
i know i feel like i already know how
you feel about this but
i mean do you like this one uh do you
think it was beer do you think it was
apple juice like give us your take
listen i don't even know if the picture
was from today you know how media is it
could have been from two years ago and
they're putting it out right now either
way
if luka doncic wants to sip a beer and
drop a 30 piece on the warriors i am
cool with it i don't care what you
pre-game with it could be gatorade it
could be water it could be apple juice
it could be beer i don't care what it is
as long as he's hitting his player prop
that's all i care about but i do think
25 plus feels like a layup for luca at
this point he's playing so well he's
very unstoppable at this point and again
like i mentioned earlier facing a
warriors team that struggles to guard
that point guard position so 25 plus for
luca seems like a walk in the park
liv
let's move on to the next
point guard on the mavericks the other
guard that they have jalen brunson uh uh
we're talking rebounds here liv we're
we're talking rebounds and
this one's a little bit of a head
scratcher for me four plus rebounds you
think jalen brunson can go out there and
grab four plus tonight
yeah i really do actually i mean we saw
him rebounding pretty well in the last
series um the only problem is the
warriors have now prioritized rebounding
as a part of their their success i think
we've seen them especially towards the
tail end of that series against the
grizzlies that rebounding became a
priority for them and it completely
changed the game for them so that being
said i do think this is a tough one for
brunson um i do think they guard him
pretty well and he has a hard time
offensively and so maybe rebounding and
assisting is the way for him to go
tonight feeding the ball to luca who
won't miss and then rebounding as much
as he can the only struggle is the
warriors are also rebounding well so
this is a tough one
we'll be sweating but as i mentioned to
you earlier before the show started
what's a good bet without a good sweat
so grab your sweat towels
everyone just
just you know it is what it is we'll be
sweating out brunson but hopefully he
gets it done for us
i do like the rocking chair wins liv
i'll be honest i do like the rocking
chair wins
but what's a bet without a good sweat i
love that i love that uh let's put the
ticket up because i want to show you
guys i want to show you guys if you guys
want to put a hundred dollars down you
will be walking away with
470.86 do not forget about the 86 cents
uh liv talk to us what are you grading
the same game parlay today
i mean pretend to act surprised here
greg but i'm going to give it a b a b
minus okay because the ogs know what it
is i don't have to explain it to the
og's in the chat that part week we
cashed and uh i gave it a b minus so
that's what we're going to keep rocking
with good vibes because good vibes only
around here winners only um so b minus
it is come on we're going to hope that
you've got good energy
hey let them know liv winners only good
vibes only and then we turn bad vibes
into good vibes you dig that's right
i'm in the comments though i'm in the
comments
uh snoopy snoopy 21 53 says very sweaty
like that uh rc italy says drink a beer
like luca put a hundred on it let's make
this money love those vibes those are
good vibes emgo blue says b minus
draymond not good others good ugh em go
blue those are bad vibes but guess what
we do we turn those into good vibes uh
one more one more
i got
i got l hunt i think i gave him a hoodie
already but i'll read his comments he
says he'll replace trey assists with
luca rebounds guess what l hunt that's
bad vibes we're going to turn that into
good vibes i think i gave you shorts or
socks earlier we're going to switch it
up and give you whatever we didn't give
you because we're sending good vibes
your way but live we talked player props
and major markets for this matchup but
i'm not done i'm not done talking about
this matchup i want to let it marinate a
little bit especially because i'm gonna
be on my way to the game later so let's
talk about a little bit more let's talk
about
the series as a whole live
before we do though
let's take a look at the current series
odds going into tonight's game there
they are you see them warriors in that
minus 230
mavericks sitting at plus 185 live you
already know i got a lot
to say about this but first i want to
hear
your thoughts
i don't think you want to hear my
thoughts because i'm not sure you're
going to like them very much greg i
this series is tough for me greg this
series is tough for me here's the deal i
would not lay any money on a bet that's
valued at minus 230 i just wouldn't do
it and that plus 185 man oh it looks so
good it looks so good this is a
mavericks team as i mentioned earlier
that's giving up the third fewest points
of their opponent they have strong
defense defense wins championships and
let's be real i know they're your team
but we have not seen the warriors play
warrior basketball we have not seen it i
haven't seen steph go off like i know he
can i haven't seen klay thompson maybe a
little in game six but we haven't seen
the consistency of the warrior squad
that i think we anticipated and now
they're facing a tough defense in the
mavericks and they have a guy
offensively the mavericks have a guy
offensively in luca that just cannot be
stopped and he's facing a warriors team
that struggles to guard point guards i
mean i i'm just i'm just saying that
plus 185 looks good and i
the mavs might win this series there i
said it and i love the plus 185 so i'm
sprinkling on it that's all i have
live
i know you you know you know like i'm
not lost for words right now i'm really
at lost
because you say you say the warriors
haven't been jealous but i'm just
confused because
4-1 against denver that's
good
4-2 i mean
4-2 against
memphis i mean
it didn't go game seven like
what else do you want them to do liv
what else do you want them to do
you mentioned you mentioned this though
i'll give you you mentioned luca and
they do have luca i'll give you that
they have luca he's a walking bucket
but liv the warriors have three they
have three of them they have three
walking buckets jordan pool can go off
at any time we saw what get clay do in
game six and stephen curry is stepping
that's three to one like
make it make sense the odds you know i
know
all right let flip i'll give you the
benefit of the dial i'll give you the
benefit you made the right betting
choice you made the right betting choice
yes minus 230 compared to plus 185 you
made the right betting choice but in
reality
in actuality and factuality i don't even
know if that's a word but come on the
warriors man i'm rocking with the home
team i see this one being done in five
or maybe six i i might give them six but
uh you guys heard from us now we want to
hear from you
what are you guys predictions for this
series get into those comments and let
us know i'm actually in the comments
right now
i'm in the comments right now uh
my man bk37 says gotta get back to work
now be great everyone he's a legend
shout out to you you're walking away
with some socks uh mkhit 93 says luca's
gonna get his
but warriors are going back to the
finals i like that i do agree with that
i agree with that 100 luca will get his
but will the mavericks the other team
will the his assets what his other
players are they going to get theirs
live and that's the question
to be answered uh in this series
[Music]
but liv i think you got to uh tell the
people
what you got going on with my man yeah
yeah you know i'm a big luca fan right
now obviously riding with the mavericks
but before we move on to the east and
talk about that a little bit something
else i have to talk about regarding this
matchup is the crazy player combo
fanduel has for luca doncic tonight 51
plus combined points rebounds and
assists for -113 odds as i mentioned
luca has to go off tonight that is the
mavericks only chance and luca also has
to do a little bit of everything
rebounding facilitating scoring so
51 plus can he get 51 plus points
rebounds sis that is the question greg
can he do it
liv i i i don't know i don't i do not
know we all know luca is gonna get his
we do know luke is gonna get his we know
he's gonna score we know he might
rebound he might get down there rebound
warrior small ball lineup i'll give that
to him the only hiccup here liv the only
hiccup that has me considering
not saying that i'm not taking it but
considering
is the assist that's the only hiccup
here i need to find out
if the mavericks players are gonna make
their shots that's what it's gonna come
down to we know luca's gonna get his
trend wise the warriors they let the
superstars be superstars
but will the other guys
come and help out
luca we will have to find out uh
we all know luca has been bawling though
we all know luke has been balling so
this is a tough one
but we asked y'all in the app we asked
y'all in the app
will he go over or under this combo here
are a few of our favorite comments my
man scotty p says i think he's up
scotty p says under i think he ups his
assists and barely misses this
but others get involved in the scoring
okay he only hits the over once this
year with 60 but was under in three
other games including totals of 36
and 41 which relatively aren't close
live those aren't close what do you but
what do you have to say about my guy
saying lucas is going under live
you think he's honest i mean you know no
he he might be because like you
mentioned like i feel like it may be one
or the other you know if the other if
his if his teammates can get a little
bit more involved on offense then he may
score less and he has more assists and
then if he if his teammates aren't as
involved then he's getting all the
points so it's the mavs are in a very
interesting spot where they rely so
heavily on luca that i think we're going
to get one or the other in in either
category whether it be assists and
facilitating or scoring himself so
interesting and i don't disagree with
scotty at all i think it's a great take
well let's move on to the next take my
man bk37 was just in the comments
but he said he still gets it
but
barely barely barely barely uh i don't
know if i agree with this one liv i do
not know what are your thoughts on it
that comment to me equals what's a good
bet without a good sweat period so
you know
bk let's just sweat it out and let's
let's barely cash and let's sweat and
have some fun how about that
let's have some fun i'm all about that
also if you guys are regulars
in our app community you know that bk 37
is a legend and he kills squad rise this
man has hit five not one not two not
three not four but five in a row and is
trying for his six tonight
and if winning us money wasn't legendary
enough he is also
a doves fan i like that guy i like that
guy scotty p and bk37
you are walking away with a pair of
custom br betting socks i need everybody
to get in the comments and tell me if
you are riding this combo let me get
into these comments and see what they
are talking about liv uh
i see g quinn 26 says sweat bets he
likes it i like that too sweat bets the
best bets uh here we go uh bomb
[Music]
bombing five says don't sweat the over
looney bed
i like that i
like that uh
m kent m kent is in the comments back
again and he says luke was going for 41
12 and 9.
i like that i don't know actually i
don't like that that's too good of a
game for the ways to win but uh
but yeah everybody that i mentioned you
all are walking away with some vr
betting custom socks all right liv we
talked through
the series that is kicking off tonight
now i want you i want to hear your
thoughts live i want to hear your
thoughts on the heat celtics series
let's bring up those current odds there
they are on your screen you see the heat
sitting at minus 150 in the boston
celtics sitting at plus
125 live talk to me talk to people
what are your thoughts here
yeah i had i had the heat to win game
one at home and i'm really happy that
they did because the value for the
celtics to win the series got better i
do like the celtics in this series i
know that obviously we're they're
missing some guys and that's tough but
uh even without two guys that are super
valuable to that team they
they played pretty well and i thought
that actually they were gonna win that
game there for a minute um i think that
this series is gonna boil down to
defense two very strong defensive teams
but uh at the end of the day i'm just
loving the way that the celtics are
playing on both sides of the ball right
now um i'm riding the siege train what
can i say i am a total bandwagon fan but
i'm rocking with them and i i've got
them to win the series with some plus
money odds so i'm liking it
i like the honesty she says i'm a total
bad wag hey i am being honest that's
that's all that matters i mean some
people appreciate the honesty live and i
am one of those people uh but
i i i don't know i
liv the seas have my heart they do i i
really want to bet on them or i want to
ride with them but the only thing is is
injuries live i
i don't know who's going to be in the
lineup or not horford didn't play my man
marcus smart didn't play
i i wonder is is that going to continue
throughout the series or
are they going to come back and and
those questions that i have just
leads me to bet if i was you know
putting the bet down right now to bet
the team that is not injured that is the
complete team and that is the miami heat
so that is who i'm rocking with for this
series i do think it's going to be a
defensive series it will i think it
might go seven liv i'll put that on
paper i said this one might go seven but
i think spoelstra
jimmy buckets
and those boys from south beach
might pull this one off uh let me get
into these comments though lift because
it's time to give out some more of these
socks
i see uh
go garden says jimmy bucket for the ring
i don't know about that if the warriors
are in the finals i do not know about
that brother uh uh rc italy rc italy
says celtics will get it done if smart
comes back jimmy buckets doesn't get 40
and tatum has less pressure on him every
possession of offense and goes to work
shout out to you you are walking away
with those br betting custom socks live
it's time to get on the body here i got
to go get i got to go watch a
got a game uh
yeah but thank you thank everybody for
tapping into the group chat presented by
fanduel remember what you learned today
the 3x2 we are all riding it as a family
and the br betting same game parlay liv
gave it a b minus and that usually means
good vibes and also do not forget we
turn bad vibes in to good vibes we are
switching it up on you next week we will
be back next tuesday giving away more
custom vr betting socks more jerseys and
of course more lots if you want a prize
we will
dm you today
all right guys you know i'll be at the
game supporting my squad tonight make
sure to follow along on br betting
social on tick tock on the instagram
story uh we are gonna be there alongside
live moves i'm craig ivory we
are leaving the group chat
[Music]
you